el cerebro es la parte más compleja del
cuerpo humano
este órgano de 1.36 kilos es la sede de
la inteligencia la base de datos de los
recuerdos interprete de los sentidos
y director de todos los movimientos
recostado en su estructura ósea y bañado
por un líquido protector el cerebro es
también el órgano más frágil en el
cuerpo con la misma textura y
consistencia de una gelatina
dentro del cerebro hay más de 100 mil
millones de células nerviosas llamadas
neuronas enviando señales eléctricas y
químicas que van y vienen en el cuerpo
cada neurona tiene un cuerpo celular una
larga fibra nerviosa llamada axón y
proyecciones de cuerpos celulares
llamados dendritas las dendritas
sobresalen del cuerpo celular para
recibir mensajes de otras células
nerviosas
los acciones en el cerebro conectan las
neuronas entre sí lo cual a su vez da
como resultado amplias interconexiones
con otras áreas cerebrales
debido a que el cerebro y sus células
nerviosas son muy frágiles los
movimientos rápidos y repentinos de la
cabeza pueden causar lesiones durante
una lesión como tal llamada lesión de
golpe y contragolpe o de aceleración
desaceleración el cerebro rebota a una y
otra vez contra la pared ósea interior
del cráneo en las lesiones de golpe y
contragolpe a gran velocidad el impacto
puede ser lo suficientemente violento
como para causar hinchazón y moretón en
el tejido cerebral llamado contusión sin
embargo en casos donde hay baja
velocidad en las lesiones de golpe y
contragolpe el daño resultante no puede
ser visible a simple vista
mientras el cerebro se mueve una y otra
vez en el cráneo las áreas de densidad
variada en el cerebro se deslizan unas a
otras en diferentes velocidades los
axones al cruzar estas intersecciones
experimentan grandes fuerzas de cizalla
miento provocando su estiramiento y
separación del cuerpo celular
este evento se llama cizallamiento
axonal o lesión axonal difusa
el daño cerebral puede continuar por
horas o días luego de la lesión inicial
y el daño de los axones puede llevar a
colapsar la comunicación entre las
neuronas del cerebro
y el desgarre de los axones se degenera
rápidamente liberando niveles tóxicos de
químicos llamados neurotransmisores en
el espacio extracelular a su vez muchas
de las neuronas circundantes empiezan a
morir dentro de las siguientes 24 a 48
horas
empeorando los efectos iniciales de la
lesión
casos leves a moderados de lesión axonal
difusa de ahí por sus siglas en inglés
pueden resultar en síntomas como breve
pérdida de la conciencia
memoria a largo plazo dañada
habilidad para la solución de problemas
reducida
e inhibición social menor
y problemas con atención y percepción
y los casos graves de lesión axonal
difusa pueden resultar en coma
o estado vegetal persistente
en los eeuu más de un millón de casos de
lesiones cerebrales traumáticas leves
incluyendo la lesión axonal difusa son
reportados cada año de este número más
de 300.000 pacientes sufren efectos a
largo plazo por el daño
y la tomografía computarizada tc y la
imagen por resonancia magnética rm son
exámenes que se pueden realizar para
revisar la lesión cerebral traumática
leve los resultados de estos exámenes
normalmente muestran una lectura normal
por lo tanto los médicos deben confiar
en la historia del paciente y en un
examen clínico para diagnosticar una
lesión cerebral traumática leve